tell me more about the global
hyperinflationary
type event what would that look like or
what would you be looking for to say yes
it's happening now
well first of all i think we're kind of
in the early innings of it of course
it's not going to be an overnight thing
uh it's more likely to kind of
also come sort of in these waves of
increasing and reducing inflation but
we're already seeing inflation
at like 42-year highs
and
personally
kind of the official government
statistics that we're seeing in the
world i think those are further sort of
artificially lowered i think just by
looking at the food prices and the real
estate prices that i myself am
experiencing
i would say
things are kind of slowly getting out of
control
now people think that it's because of
supply side reasons uh i still think
that the majority driver of that is sort
of the insanely aggressive monetary
expansion that we've seen sort of spring
2020 onward
um but essentially there's a kind of a
one of the
less spoken about debates in the bitcoin
world is whether
the transition
from
fiat to crypto whether it's going to be
a peaceful one and there's definitely a
path for that as well
or it's going to be more turbulent now
in the last three or four months we're
already seeing sort of some civil unrest
around the world
uh albania sri lanka
tunisia
kosovo serbia etc
and in my opinion
um sort of
if you look at history
rising sort of bread and energy prices
have always been the biggest and the
most frequent sort of causer of um any
kind of upheaval or unrest right so
uh definitely just something to consider
definitely something to think about uh
as we sort of move forward in in this
age of rapid change i would say
talk to me about the central banks
around the world and their role uh
through market intervention in creating
some of these scenarios versus uh is it
external shocks and external event
developments that they're simply trying
to respond to
and you can't really lay
fault or blame
with the central banks for either the
40-year high of inflation that many
countries are seeing
or things like a potential recession
which i would argue is a recession in
the united states
so i believe that a fractional reserve
based banking system cannot survive
without intermittent interventions of
central banks into the economy
as i'm sure many other guests on your
podcasts have alluded to in the past
this creates all kinds of distortions uh
when it comes to uh sort of the the
correct pricing of goods
more importantly and something that's
less talked about
is i believe
that
the government intervention in the
currency markets
it
makes inflation a lot higher than it has
to be which in turn
i believe is kind of the primary cause
of
mental health issues
stress
anxiety because essentially
it forces you at the margin to
prioritize short-term projects over
long-term projects
and because of that
people essentially uh not just
financially but also psychologically are
essentially like living week to week if
not day to day
and that creates a lot of discomfort in
people's minds right and i think that
this is like one of the one of the 12 13
things that is is less discussed and
something that hopefully will change for
the better once we kind of move to sound
or system in the coming years
you've mentioned a couple of times that
that transition could be peaceful or it
could be a little bit more turbulent
what is your kind of description of both
of those scenarios what does the
peaceful transition look like is it just
people start buying something like
bitcoin and over time the percentage
increases and and then everyone starts
using that and then also what does the
turbulent time look like in your opinion
given the facts and information that we
have today
so i guess i i kind of described a
similar metaphor a few years back but
effectively both fiat and bitcoin are
just two balloons right and with every
boom and bust cycle that we have
in uh bitcoin effectively the peak of
each of the bull cycles is essentially
an attention wave right and with each of
those attention waves usually the
majority of the majority of the
participant the majority of new
participants of each generation in
bitcoin cycles predominantly comes at
the top and it's designed to be that way
right because with the top comes the
greatest amount of hype news marketing
attention right and
each of these sort of heartbeats so to
speak um
brings more people from the fiat from
the fiat balloon into the bitcoin
balloon
and um
the peaceful scenario is one where that
transition happens sort of gently
slowly
gradually and instead of a large number
of people in the world being caught off
guard
um by sort of the entirety of the
current monetary paradigm sort of
blowing apart you have a relatively
sizable chunk of them already in the
bitcoin system or in the cryptocurrency
system and the infrastructure to move
from one to another is already sort of
very well established and sort of that
movement of air so to speak from one
balloon to another it happens gradually
steadily peacefully and fiat instead of
um
exploding so to speak it slowly
uh sort of
fades into irrelevance instead right
i don't know how realistic that is of
course that is the preferable way
but i think a darker pill so to speak is
that the exist the very existence of
bitcoin
is probably
going to end up accelerating
and more rapid and sort of explosive
collapse of the current monetary system
in my opinion right now we don't know
when that's going to happen but like i
said i think it's going to happen in the
next several decades
uh but
personally
i lean towards sort of a more turbulent
scenario